Gut, okay, dann darf ich euch recht herzlich begrüßen zum Meteo-App-Abend.
Ich würde ganz gerne, bevor es jetzt losgeht, noch ganz kurz ein paar Reden festlegen.
Am besten schalten alle das Mikrofon aus, außer mir.
Wenn ihr Fragen habt, dann könnt ihr gerne unten, die meisten kennen das von der Funktion her, die Hand geben.
Oder es gibt da noch den Chat-Bereich, wo man dann was reinschreiben könnte.
Aber am liebsten wäre mir eigentlich die Hand heben, dann sehe ich das und dann kann ich auf die Frage dann reagieren.
Nach circa 40 Minuten, also schon vorher, weil das ist eine Gratis-Version Zoom, das heißt so bei 40 Minuten ist eigentlich schon fertig.
Dann machen wir sicher auch eine kurze Pause, nutzen natürlich das Rad und dann...
Da werde ich nachher wieder einen neuen Link per WhatsApp schicken für die nächste Sitzung.
Ich denke, mit zwei soll das gut reichen.
Kann ich aber den genauen Fahrplan nicht sagen.
Es kann ja sein, dass doch ein paar mehr Fragen auftauchen und ich dann ein bisschen länger bin.
Gut, dann würde ich gerne warten.
Mein Thema heute Abend ist eigentlich einmal die einzelnen Apps, die ich benutze, einmal durchzuschauen.
Wir gehen vor der Funktionsweise, beziehungsweise was für Möglichkeiten mit den Apps mittlerweile vorhanden sind
und was für Einstellungen da teilweise von mir gemacht wurden, einfach um da einen besseren Überblick zu schaffen.
Und am Ende gehen wir dann auch nochmal die einzelnen Daten durch, speziell für Windwolken, Großwetterlage.
Also da machen wir...
Da machen wir dann schon nochmal konkrete Analyse.
Aber zuerst würde ich euch gerne die einzelnen Apps von der Funktion zeigen
und nachher dann ein bisschen mehr ins Detail, was jetzt die Prognose angeht.
Gut, dann würde ich da starten.
Ich zeige Ihnen mal den Bildschirm, damit ihr weiß, wo das geht.
Solltet ihr jetzt meinen Browser sehen, könnt ihr das sehen.
Da als Browser vielleicht kurze Reaktion, was bei euch sichtbar ist.
Ich muss mal schnell die Funktion...
Das ist schwierig so.
Alles klar, wunderbar.
Dann gehen wir da wieder zurück.
Okay.
Also, das ist die erste App.
Windel sind die meisten mit dem gleichen Bier.
Bevor wir jetzt nachher auf die App...
...in die App selber eingehen, würde ich gerne euch die Einstellungen zeigen.
Das würde ich euch empfehlen abzuändern, wenn das nicht schon einige von euch getan haben.
Und zwar generell auch für den Wind, für uns halt gebräuchlicher KMH, Temperatur,
den Druck Hektopascal.
Das sind einfach so Grundeinstellungen, die ihr hier unter dem Menüpunkt da oben rechts aufklicken.
Dann Einstellungen.
Und dann habt ihr das vor euch liegen und könnt da gewisse Einstellungen vornehmen.
Windanimation normal oder hoch.
Hoch ist okay.
Je höher das es wird, habe ich das Gefühl, umso unübersichtlicher wird es.
Entschuldigung, die Dichte meine ich hier.
Je höher man die Dichte macht, umso unübersichtlicher wird es.
Mach mal.
Aber wenn man die Animation hoch einstellt und die Dichte etwas höher,
dann kann man doch stärkeren Wind oder weniger Wind ein bisschen besser unterscheiden aus meiner Sicht.
Wenn man da so reinzoomt, dann sieht man halt schon deutlich mehr Partikelströmung und deutlich mehr Wind.
Macht es manchmal ein bisschen übersichtlich, aber ich habe es gerne nicht zu dicht.
Dann haben wir da auf der rechten Seite die verschiedenen Auswahlmöglichkeiten voreingestellt.
Der Wind ist auch für uns am meisten wichtig oder am relevantesten.
Aber es gibt noch sehr, sehr viele andere coole Funktionen, unter anderem Mietenbilder, die dann wichtig sind für Wolken.
Radar habe ich jetzt nicht so gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Regengewitter.
Auf der rechten Seite auch Niederschlag mit dazu.
Muss ich ehrlich gestehen, hatte jetzt bei Windy, gerade jetzt für die Schweiz, noch nicht unbedingt so perfekte Prognosen gebracht.
Also ich konzentriere mich bei Windy tatsächlich auf Wind, ab und an, gerade im Ausland, mal noch Wolken.
Und zweitwichtig bei Windy ist sicher die Temperatur.
Das ist nämlich ein cooles Beispiel, gerade heute, um den Föhn vielleicht bei schwierigeren Situationen, wenn es dann weniger wie 4 Hektopascal hat, noch ablesen zu können mit der Temperaturdifferenz zwischen Süd-Alpen-Hauptkampf und nördlich.
Und das Thema, dass wir da eine ordentliche Differenz haben.
Jetzt sollte dann immer die Höhe dazu, wenn wir hier rechts...
... dann einstellen, die Höhe auf ca. 2000 Meter nehmen.
Dann ist es sehr gut, dass wir da eine starke Differenz haben.
Und dadurch auch wirklich der Föhn sehr stark im Gang ist.
Wie gesagt, ihr habt dazu auch auch wieder die Höhe für den jeweiligen Wind beispielsweise, wo ihr auswählen könnt.
Das macht für uns natürlich sehr gut.
Wir können mal deutlicher kommen.
deutlich höher gehen und schauen, ein bisschen mehr rauszoomen.
Da hat Windy wirklich alle Optionen vorhanden und man kann wirklich sehr gut Starkwindwänder erkennen.
Wenn wir da jetzt mal auf eine geringere Höhe gehen, wo es ein bisschen spannender wird,
vielleicht einmal 1000 Meter, dann kann man mit einem Blick bei Windy sehr gut ausmachen,
wie stark ist jetzt der Wind vielleicht in unserem Raum und wo ist da das nächste, doch stärkere Windband?
Ist es in unmittelbarer Nähe von uns oder wie jetzt hier zu sehen,
also wohlgemerkt auf geringer Höhe von knapp 1000 Metern, ja im Mittelland, oder?
Also das macht Windy für mich eigentlich schon zu einer ganz speziellen Darstellung,
weil man wirklich sehr präsentiert.
Und man ist auch sehr bereit, sehen kann, wo hat Starkwind, wo eher weniger Wind.
Also finde ich ganz lässig und macht eben auch sehr gut sichtbar.
Dann haben wir die Möglichkeit, verschiedene Wettermodelle auszuwählen.
Das haben wir da unten.
Wir haben auch noch zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit, Gleitdämmstabplätze mit einzublenden.
Wobei das auch jetzt nicht...
Man kann auch noch mal den Wind...
Mit Anzeige und Stärke dort als Zahl angeben lassen.
Finde ich aber, macht alles nachher wieder ein bisschen unübersichtlicher.
Darum nehme ich da am Anfang immer sehr wenig generelle Informationen mit rein.
Was ich voreingestellt habe, was permanent aufleuchtet, ist die Partikelanimation.
Ich denke, das ist bei den meisten der Fall.
Was ihr aber noch hinstellen könnt, was aus meiner Sicht auch sinnvoll ist,
sind die Isobaren, also die Linien mit gleichem Druck.
Und anhand von dem kann man nämlich auch schon sehr viel ablesen.
Und das Coole ist, da unten mit der Zeitakte kann man dann eben auch noch ein bisschen vorausgehen
und schauen, wie sich denn Hoch- und Tiefdruck generell verschieben.
Also finde ich ganz lässig.
Man kann dann wirklich auch weit im Voraus das Ganze mal anschauen, ob es so kommt.
Das wisst ihr selber.
Das würde ich jetzt mal nicht für wahre Münze nehmen.
Alles, was mehr wie zwei Tage hinaus ist, ist reine Spekulation für mich und drum.
Aber sicher mal gut zu sehen und aus meiner Sicht sehr hilfreich, die Isobaren.
Darum habe ich die permanent eingestellt.
Je nach Modell.
Also es gibt...
Ihr könnt dann auch schauen, wann die aktualisiert werden.
Müsst ihr dazu dann auf den Info-Button klicken.
Dann habt ihr da das jeweilige Modell mit dem Raster, mit dem gerechnet wird.
Neun Kilometer Raster, europäisches Modell.
Und dann seht ihr, wie oft das Ganze aktualisiert wird.
Sechs bis sieben Stunden Intervall.
Man ist eigentlich nicht so...
Aber dann wisst ihr auch, okay, in circa anderthalb Stunden kommt der Update.
Das heißt, es macht nicht unbedingt Sinn, alle paar Minuten reinzuschauen.
Weil schließlich wird das Ganze ein paar Mal über den Tag hinweg abgedatet.
Und die Info könnt ihr da herausnehmen.
Wenn wir dann da mal auf das eigenes Deutsch nutzen.
Vom deutschen Wetterdienst gehen.
Da seht ihr, das wird alle drei bis fünf Stunden aktualisiert.
Also deutlich kürzere Intervalle.
Man sieht aber auch schon, wenn wir jetzt hier herauszoomen,
dass das deutsche Modell auch nicht so einen großen Bereich abdeckt.
Das heißt, wenn man in Spanien unterwegs ist unten,
und hier vor einem das europäische Modell mit dem 2,2 Kilometer Raster ist,
dann muss man dann wieder etwas...
...größer gehen.
Eiken, EU mit 7 Kilometern oder mit 13 Kilometern.
Also da seht ihr, da habt ihr die verschiedensten Modelle.
Ich persönlich arbeite am Anfang, um mir mal einen groben Überblick zu schaffen.
Also je weiter weg meine Prognose ist,
umso eher schaffe ich mal mit dem europäischen Modell als Grundbasis.
Und je näher das Ganze herkommt,
auch mit...
...umso eher geht dann mal etwas kleinerastiger vor.
Bei uns in der Schweiz,
oder besser gesagt im Alpenraum,
da nehme ich dann wirklich sehr, sehr gern das Eiken D2.
Das passt vor der Häufigkeit doch sehr gut.
Und ich finde gerade für unsere Region,
dass die Prognosen doch deutlich oder sehr oft zutreffen.
Auch nicht immer, aber schon...
Also das zu den Inputs, das könnt ihr alles dort herausnehmen.
Und die verschiedenen Modelle,
da müsst ihr halt auch für eure Region dann mit der Zeit mal abgleichen,
feststellen, was ist für euch besser und besser oder zutreffender.
Dann gibt es ganz, ganz coole,
ja auch über die ganze Woche hinweg,
eine allgemeine Möglichkeit,
das Wetter noch ein bisschen differenzierter anzuschauen.
Also mal nicht nur den Wind,
sondern generell ein bisschen alles im Überblick.
Wenn wir mal auf unsere Region,
dann habt ihr da die Möglichkeit,
einen speziellen Moment mal,
normalerweise diese Ansicht wird dann geöffnet.
Da habt ihr dann ganz einfach und simpel Wolken, Sonnensymbole.
Ihr habt mal den Boden, den ihr da mit reingeblendet.
Ihr habt sogar Niederschlag mit eingeblendet.
Aber das ist dann doch,
eher für die gröberen Prognosen gedacht.
Für uns im Speziellen,
man kann sogenannte Meteorogramme aufrufen.
Oder was für uns eigentlich sogar noch ein bisschen besser ist,
weil auch noch der Wind detaillierter über die Höhen mit reingeblendet wird,
ist das sogenannte Airgram.
Also ihr könnt da sehen, die verschiedenen Höhen,
der Wind in der verschiedenen Höhe,
über den Tag verteilt.
Ihr habt dort unten eine Einblendung,
welche Wolken in welchem Stockwert vermutlich anzutreffen sind.
Und ihr habt dort auch noch dann die Niederschlagsprognose mit dazu reingenommen.
Also sind die eigentlich sehr gut und spannend.
Auch da könnt ihr dann zwischen den einzelnen Modellen switchen
und dann erhaltet ihr die Prognose von denen.
Das andere ist,
das amerikanische Modell,
das ist das Modell,
was schon am längsten aufzeichnet,
also wo am meisten Daten vorhanden sind,
hat allerdings auch das größte Raster mit 22 Kilometern.
Und das nehme ich tatsächlich nur noch mit in Gebrauch,
wenn ich noch länger wie eine Woche eine Prognose anschaue.
Weil alles andere ist dann aus meiner Sicht dann mittlerweile
doch eher ungenau geworden.
Und jetzt kommt noch eine ganz coole Funktion da bei der Möglichkeit.
Also ihr seht hier unten,
ich habe eine 1-Stunde-Vorhersage.
Das ist nur möglich,
wenn man das Abo gelöst hat bei Windy.
Das kostet 18 Euro irgendwas.
Also es ist wirklich nicht teuer.
Da muss man dann selber entscheiden, ob es einsatzwert ist oder nicht.
Aber jetzt kommt eine ganz tolle Funktion.
Und zwar kann man hier
mit vergleichen,
kann man jetzt die ganzen Modelle miteinander vergleichen
auf den einzelnen Tag.
Das heißt, wenn hier, wie jetzt für den morgigen Tag,
bei praktisch allen Modellen kein Niederschlag vorhergesagt wird,
dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass das auch so kommt.
Wenn sich alle uneinig finden,
der eine sagt Niederschlag, der andere nicht, der andere wieder,
dann ist es eher ein bisschen schwieriger,
aber wenn es dann so eindeutig ist wie hier,
dann kann man davon ausgehen,
da gibt es definitiv keinen Niederschlag.
Und das finde ich eigentlich noch eine sehr coole Funktion.
Hat mir beispielsweise in Indien doch sehr gut geholfen,
schnell auch zu sehen,
welche Modelle noch besser an dem Ort funktionieren als andere.
Aber das finde ich jetzt wiederum eine sehr, sehr coole Funktion.
Ja, Windy, noch ein ganz spezielles Tool,
wenn man jetzt die Thermik noch analysieren möchte.
Allerdings ist das hier ein bisschen schwieriger,
weil man muss schon deutlich mehr vom Hemogramm verstehen.
Ich mache mal ein Beispiel, wenn wir da rein schwitzen
und ich hier in unserer Region auf den Talboden gehe,
machen wir das im Klima.
Dann müsst ihr mit der Maus rechts klicken
und dann öffnet sich noch einmal ein Raster
mit verschiedenen Möglichkeiten.
Und dann müsst ihr auf ganz unten Aerologie gehen
und dann öffnet sich rechts das sogenannte Hemogramm
oder Temp, wie die Deutschen dazu sagen.
Und ich habe das hier unten auf QC gestellt.
Also man kann die normale Ansicht,
den Namen nicht jetzt überraten,
oder man kann das Ganze auf QC und das, was ich benutze,
mit dem habe ich gelernt, umzugehen.
Und dann kann man dort eigentlich auch die Temperaturkurve
dort unten analysieren.
Was ganz cool ist, seht ihr jetzt eingeblendet,
wenn ihr da mit dem Cursor hin und herfahrt,
dann könnt ihr eigentlich auch die Wolkenbasis
mit Wolkenobergrenze ganz einfach herauslesen.
Aber man muss natürlich schon im Genus
generell wissen, wie man damit umgeht.
Das heißt, es hilft einem nichts,
wenn man schon vorher mit dem Hemogramm
nicht wirklich viel zu tun hat.
Aber es ist sehr gut möglich,
da die Wolkenbasis herauszulesen.
Für diejenigen, die das können oder brauchen,
die können zumindest anhand von der Temperatur
der Zustandskurve mit Hammig oder eben nicht Hammig einordnen.
Also da ist jetzt noch eingestellt das EFS-Modell.
Da kann man wirklich zwischen den einzelnen Modellen schwitzen.
Und man sieht, dass das deutsche Modell
schon ganz anders rechnet als jetzt das amerikanische.
Und was für euch eigentlich sehr gut sichtbar ist,
ist diese rote Kurve.
Da kann man schauen, wie steil geht jetzt die Kurve nach oben,
nimmt die Temperatur gut ab
oder haben wir wie dort unten eine Zunahme,
also eine Inversion drinnen.
Dann könnt ihr mit einem Blick mal schauen,
wie weit sind die Temperaturen
und Temperatur und Blaupunkt auseinander.
Das heißt, gibt es weniger Wolkenbildung
oder wie dort oben eine permanente Wolkenbildung.
Dazu habt ihr links an dem Balken an der Höhenlinie
sozusagen auch noch ein Anzeichen für die Bewölkung.
Also ist eigentlich sehr viel Information vorhanden.
Man muss es halt herauslesen können.
Bei dem SKU-T sind eben die Temperaturlinien so.
Die sind regional angeordnet.
Man braucht da vielleicht auch nicht gewisse Zeit,
bis man sich da mal vertraut gemacht hat.
Aber für mich persönlich ist das sicher eines der besten Tools,
um jetzt sich da auf den entsprechenden Tag thermisch vorzubereiten.
Gut, also ihr seht eigentlich wirklich sehr, sehr viele Funktionen.
Beim Wind könnt ihr da die einzelnen Höhen durchspielen.
Das ist halt so, je kleiner das Raster wird,
umso weniger weit könnt ihr in die Zukunft blicken.
Und teilweise seid ihr eben auch beschränkt mit der Höhe.
Das geht jetzt hier noch.
Aber bei dem 1,3 Kilometer Raster,
da könnt ihr meines Wissens eben nur den Bodenwind anschauen.
Was jetzt vielleicht für die Windbildung ganz gut wäre,
weil es geht nur um den reinen Boden.
Aber ansonsten brauchen wir nicht so wirklich viel Prognosen für den Bodenwind.
Aber je nach Raster könnt ihr eben nicht so weit in die Zukunft blicken.
Darum empfehle ich am Anfang immer,
für weit in die Zukunft blicken zu können.
Schaut einmal, wie weit wir da mittlerweile blicken können.
Und damit wenigstens einmal eine Planung machen zu können,
dass europäische Raster und dann je nach Ort,
also in Spanien habe ich unten,
habe ich das Zeichen EU7 genommen.
Schauen wir mal schnell da drauf.
Das hat in Spanien auch funktioniert.
Wobei in Spanien Windy eigentlich von der Prognose her
ziemlich oft nicht gut funktioniert hat.
Also da müsst ihr wirklich je nach Ort herausblicken,
wie zuverlässig die Prognose ist.
In Indien super.
In Spanien jetzt nicht ganz so gut.
Da war dann das zweite App, auf das wir gleich zu sprechen kommen,
deutlich besser, muss ich sagen.
Also die Trefferquote war deutlich höher.
Aber eben, wie gesagt, das Rein- und Rauszoomen
macht Bereiche deutlich erheblicher.
Und ich empfehle euch immer, von oben herab zu beginnen,
also weiter raus zu zoomen
und dann immer weiter ins Bildteil zu gehen.
Das ist sowieso für jede Prognose da von Vorteil.
Keine Hände.
Alles gut. Wunderbar.
Okay.
Eigentlich schon soweit alles.
Wie gesagt, habt ihr noch so viel möglich.
Haut euch da mal durch.
Man kann sich da auch ein bisschen verlieren.
Jetzt gerade für Wolken
würde ich diesen Bild auch noch mit zunehmen.
Empfehlen.
Aber gerade im Ausland
sehr selten gepasst.
Nimmt da die Prognose wirklich mit Vorsicht.
Also man kann da unten auch auf diese Ansicht gehen.
Wolken, mal eine Prognose weg vom Satellitenbild.
Wenn man weiter in die Zukunft schauen möchte
und hat leider nicht so gut funktioniert bisher im Ausland.
Da an so einem Tag wie jetzt am Freitag,
wo es eh schon klar ist, dass tiefe Wolken
reinkommen mit derer Front,
dann stimmt auch da die Prognose.
Aber an Tagen, wo es noch ein bisschen schwieriger ist,
bin ich bisher nicht so glücklich gefahren.
Das gleiche gilt ebenfalls für
für den Niederschlag im Gannerrennen.
Da gehen wir nachher bei den anderen Apps ein bisschen weiter drauf rein.
Gut. Dann würde ich da Windi Erzeugich mal soweit verlassen.
Und dann mal aufs nächste App gehen.
Das wäre Meteo Karakor.
Das ist eine meiner absoluten Lieblings-Apps,
weil es einfach von der Darstellung her aus meiner Sicht
schon fast nichts Besseres gibt.
Nichts Einfacheres, nichts Übersichtlicheres mit einem Blick.
Also finde ich schon herausragend.
Wir haben nur 10 Minuten Zeit und sind gerade benachrichtigt worden.
Also haben wir mal noch 8 Minuten.
Und dann werde ich dann nachher eine neue Sitzung starten.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das ist auch zahlungspflichtig.
Wenn nicht, wenn man die Basis bzw. die Gratisversion nutzt,
dann ist ein Algorithmus hinter mir,
der irgendeinen Tag oder manchmal sogar mehrere Tage sperrt.
Das heißt, man weiß auch nicht, welchen Tag.
Es kann der morgige Tag sein.
Es kann der heutige Tag sein.
Also man ist quasi, wenn man permanent darauf zurückgreifen möchte,
so fast wie unten da das Apotheken.
Aber auch da, das kostet 24 Euro für ein ganzes Jahr,
ist eigentlich sehr preiswert und bietet eigentlich gerade
für den Normalpiloten fast alles, was man braucht.
Windprognose, Thermoprognose, Wolkenmenge, Niederschlagsmenge, Thermikhöhe,
mit Farben unterteilt sogar eine Stärke.
Also es ist eigentlich alles vorhanden.
Von dem her finde ich das wirklich sehr gut.
Was hier nicht ganz so einfach ist, ist den Gesamtüberblick zu machen.
Also man kann natürlich auch weiter rauszoomen.
Aber so von der direkten Ansicht, wo habt,
Gebiete mit stärkerem Wind, finde ich windy deutlich besser gemacht.
Aber wenn man da ins Detail geht,
und da empfehle ich euch genau, wenn ihr das macht,
dass ihr nicht einfach nur den Ort für euch anschaut,
sondern vielleicht auch Orte in näherer Umgebung mal abrufen.
Was ist jetzt passiert?
Habt ihr noch meinen Bildschirm?
Ich kann vielleicht schnell jemanden angeben und fragen, ob ihr...
Ja, okay, alles klar. Ihr habt noch meinen Bildschirm.
Wie gesagt, da solltet ihr schauen, dass ihr in der Umgebung bleibt.
Nicht nur bei euch an dem Ort, wo ihr fliegt,
sondern auch den Wind dann in der Umgebung anschaut.
Und bei mir wird das automatisch veröffnet,
aber bei euch sieht das am Anfang so aus.
Und wenn ihr da rechts auf das Diagramm klickt,
dann erhaltet ihr eine gute Darstellung.
Ihr habt da die Höhe, ihr habt da den ganzen Grad verteilt.
Also von 5, 6, 7, 8 bis am Ende.
Und am Abend aufgezeichnet wird der Wind in der verschiedenen Höhe
mit Teilen vor der Strecke.
Also je stärker der Wind, umso dicker.
Und je dunkler, umso stärker der Wind.
Sogar spezifisch für das Gleitschirm sind die ausgerichtet.
Also grün und gelb sind noch fliegbar.
Und bei orange-rot wird es dann nicht mehr fliegbar.
Und ich finde das einfach von der Darstellung her extrem gut.
Man kann sofort mit einem Blick erkennen,
in welcher Höhe hat es enorm viel Wind.
Oder wie jetzt hier beispielsweise.
Ja, da nimmt der Wind extrem gut.
Was man bei MeteoParapo aufpassen muss,
oder aufpassen muss, einfach bedenken muss,
man kann gut 5 bis manchmal 10, manchmal sogar 15 Grad,
abziehen.
Also Sie rechnen gern zu stark.
Aber das ist mir lieber als umgekehrt.
Was aber sehr gut funktioniert, ist die Richtung.
Und ich habe erst gestern wieder eine Nachricht bekommen vom PiPi,
der in Spanien immer noch unterwegs ist.
Und da hat MeteoParapo wieder eine absolute Pumpprognose gebracht.
Also es hat mit der Zeit, mit der Stärke sogar,
und der Windrichtung perfekt gepasst.
Und so kann man natürlich dann auch sehr, sehr gut arbeiten entscheiden,
wo geht man hin.
Und MeteoParapo, muss ich sagen, trifft jetzt bei uns,
gerade gab es den schon gar nicht so oft so gut zu,
aber im Ausland hervorragend.
Also sollte die ins Ausland gehen, ist MeteoParapo fast schon Pflicht,
weil das extrem gut funktioniert.
Und das Tolle ist, ihr habt mit dazu mit einem Blick noch die Wolkenmenge
oder in welchem Stockwerk die Wolke angesiedelt ist.
Das seht ihr dann hier, diese Wolken.
Wenn es einen Niederschlag hat,
ich gehe mal zurück auf Freitag,
darf man jetzt einen Niederschlag haben,
da seht ihr dann auch die Wolken im Stockwerk bis teilweise ganz runter.
Und dann seht ihr dort unten,
mit 0,2, 0,1, da kommt noch der Niederschlag mit dazu.
Eigentlich alles, was man braucht.
Und das wirklich im Überblick für den ganzen Tag zu sein.
Und auch da ist es mittlerweile so, das war am Anfang nicht ganz gegeben,
aber jetzt ist es so, dass man sich Daten im Voraus anschauen kann.
Und ich finde einfach von der Darstellung her,
wo man schnell mit einem Blick sich einen Überblick verschaffen kann,
wie es im ganzen Tag zu sein auszusehen hat.
Wenn wir jetzt zurückgehen zum Wind,
wo ja für den Wind eigentlich auch super ist,
aber wenn wir jetzt da den ganzen Donnerstag anschauen,
dann müssen wir für die Uhrzeit jeweils jede einzelne Höhe durchgehen.
Das heißt, wir müssen schauen, was ist auf 2.000 Metern der Fall,
oder auf 3.000 Metern, 4.000, also wir müssen jede Höhe durchgehen.
Und wir müssen uns das merken.
Ah ja, da am 6. am Abend beispielsweise,
da hat es auf 2.000 Metern ordentliche Wind zu machen.
Das muss man sich da wirklich merken und benötigt natürlich auch viel Zeit.
Wenn wir da wieder den Sprung machen zum Métroparaton,
ich habe noch zwei Minuten, wenn wir da zurückgehen auf den Métroparaton,
dann haben wir mit einem Blick, sehen wir sofort,
beispielsweise, wann der Wind von unten extrem zunimmt.
Also wir haben hier vielleicht noch in der unteren Sicht einen Bereich,
der ganz gut oder brauchbar wäre, aber bereits eine Stunde später
haben wir da ordentliche Windzunahme von ab 17 Uhr.
Der Sturm bricht da extrem bis unten durch.
Ich finde, das macht es extrem schnell sichtbar.
Wann haben wir ein Problem?
Wann ist es kein Problem vielleicht?
Wann ist es noch gut fliegbar?
Und wann muss man wirklich aufpassen?
Das finde ich sehr, sehr gut.
Dann haben wir da oben rechts, neben dem Diagramm,
haben wir noch die Thermik sozusagen.
Also auch hier könnt ihr dann natürlich noch
die Einstellung wechseln zwischen KMH-Fluten und Métroparaton.
Ich habe immer gern KMH.
Und da ist jetzt aus meiner Sicht auch wieder für den Benutzer freundlich
das M-A-Gramm abgeändert worden.
Das heißt, man hat eine ganz eigene Interpretation von diesem M-A-Gramm hergestellt.
Und zwar hat man das so gemacht, dass man diese rechte Zustandskurve
mit eigenen Farben erkennbar macht.
Das heißt, Schwarz ist eigentlich eine eher stabile Schichtung.
Also Temperaturgradient ist, nimmt ganz minim ab
oder ist manchmal vielleicht sogar gleichbleibend.
Also Isotomie oder eine Invasion, wo es wirklich stabilisierend machen würde.
Und der grüne Bereich ist schon ein Bereich,
wo zwar immer noch wenig labil ist, aber für uns schon brauchbarer.
Also darum auch grün.
Thermisch gesehen eher brauchbar für uns.
Und Rot wäre jetzt für uns sehr stark.
Also schon fast nicht mehr blutbar.
Nicht mal mehr eine Minute.
Wir werden das dann gleich an der Stelle stoppen.
Gehe dann nachher da nochmal auf dieses M-A-Gramm ein.
Beziehungsweise auf den Temp von Meta-Power.
Ich will das aber jetzt hier beenden.
Und schicke euch gleich, wenn die Saison, wenn die Dinge...